it's just another way of locating a
point in a plane see before when we
talked about rectangular coordinates x
and y-coordinates we talked about you
know going left or right if it's the
x-coordinate up and down if it's the
y-coordinate it's kind of like one of
those etch-a-scketches you can only go
left and right up and down here with
polar what we're doing is we're actually
talking about a circular way okay of
locating a point so we've got R which is
the radius so you can see this is like
polar graph paper here you're going out
to a specific radius a circle of radius
one a circle of radius two radius three
and so on and then you're rotating along
that circle a certain number of degrees
or a certain number of radians remember
positive it's counterclockwise and
negative if it's clockwise so let's look
at some examples together so you can
understand how to work with these so say
we wanted to locate point a it's at 3
comma 45 degrees so this means a circle
of radius 3 and an angle of 45 degrees
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
go over here 1 2 3 and then I'm gonna
rotate 45 degrees right there that's
point a now you might be saying yourself
Mario isn't there another way that I can
locate this point couldn't I like go
this direction since its circular and
you're absolutely right and another way
of locating this point there's many ways
of doing this an infinite way ways a
matter of fact but what we could do is
we could say well this is a negative 3
now it's a negative what we can do is we
can go left 3 and then since we're going
to go clockwise now we could go a
negative 135 degrees that's another way
of locating that same point we could
also go positive 3 and then rotate like
this okay so how much would that be 3
comma negative 315 and so on but what I
like to do when it's a negative radius
is I like to go first left and then
rotate from there now other people what
they like to do is they like to rotate
the hundred and thirty-five degrees
let's see negative which would be right
over here okay
and then what they'll do is we'll go
through this origin they call that point
the pole and they'll go 180 degrees but
I find that to be a little bit confusing
for students so I like to go you know
left if it's negative and then rotate
from there let's go to the second
a point B 2 comma negative 60 all right
so that means we're on a circle of
radius 2 negative 60 so negative 60
means what means we're going clockwise
60 degrees that's going to put you right
there that's point B now what's another
way of locating that same point well
let's see how about if we go negative 2
this time so that would be negative 2
I'm going to the left and then we're
gonna go a hundred and twenty degrees
you would end up in the exact same point
or you could do let's see you could do
positive two and then you could go all
the way around like that so how many
degrees would that be 300 right so 2
comma 300 degrees but the main thing is
you've got R and theta or radius and an
angle as opposed to x and y left and
right we've got a couple more examples
these ones are in radians but before I
do those with you I just wanted to
mention if you're preparing for the AC T
or the SAT check out my huge AC T math
review video course for my huge SAT math
review video course we go through
numerous examples numerous formulas you
have an opportunity to practice and we
talk about some of the concepts as you
would see them on those tests so check
out some of the free previews a lot of
students have taken those courses
already and have benefited and raised
their scores so check those out but
let's go into these last two examples
negative 5 PI over 2 so negative 5 means
I'm going to go to circle 5 1 2 3 4 5
I'm going to the left because it's
negative PI over 2 that's a positive
angle which means I'm going
counterclockwise and I'm going to end up
right there that's Point C what's
another way to locate that same point
well we could go positive 5 so that's
going to the right 5 and then we could
go negative PI over 2 that's another way
to locate that same point and there's an
infinite number of ways but let's look
at the last example negative 1 negative
3 PI over 2 so negative 1 means we're
going left 1 and then negative 3 PI over
2 means we're going clockwise and we end
up right here and that's going to be
point D of course you could go let's see
we could go positive 1 and you can just
go negative PI over 2 but again remember
if you're going counterclockwise that's
positive if you're going clockwise
that's negative and it doesn't matter
you know if you're going with the
negative radius still clockwise is
you know clockwise is going to be what
this direction that's negative and
counterclockwise is going to be positive
so I hope that helps you to understand
how to work with polar coordinates
better I'm gonna have some other videos
talking about how to change forms
between rectangular and polar so check
out those videos if you're interested
subscribe to the channel
check out more math tutoring videos on
my youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
and I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon